when you look at the documentary do you
see like where did they go wrong like
are there things that obviously they
blew out of proportion I mean obviously
they you know tried to classify or make
it just vaguely look like your your
granddaughter could be what you know a
woman you're dating or something but
what else do they do what else did they
capture wrong or what else did we not
get the true story on when you look at
it I mean the huge line they stepped
over was there at the end
bringing up on the black screen that
they have asked me about some
inappropriateness with tiger cubs and I
haven't answered but in fact these guys
talked to me for maybe five full days of
filming and three or four half days they
asked me every question in the world 99%
of them had nothing to do with anything
to become a gang and they just pick and
chose little pieces of course I run this
incredible world-class operation
I have tiger cubs that live with me
cradle-to-grave no Tiger babies are ever
going to be euthanized they're ever
gonna be pushed out of the way they're
incredibly precious to us all the way
from what they provide us to their very
nature who they have hyper value they're
super rare
we are reproduce that have all been
genetically tested from the time they're
young and from their grandparents and
great-grandparents and we genetically
test them to know that these are some of
the most genetically diverse Tigers on
earth the only ones left on the planet
with this genetic makeup we've done
house through world-class genetics that
continue to work for us with us and
those guys have been able to see this
incredibly rare opportunity that we have
and this is a bank against the potential
eventual extinction Tigers are super
rare they all know yeah I never see a
tiger you can go buy a tiger that's just
a complete joke I cannot go buy a tiger
I know everybody that's ever been around
99% of everyone who ever used to do it
is dawn there is no one that has a tiger
for sale that you can solicit and find
it is a felony it you know yeah you can
buy some heroin I guess somewhere but
it's a heck of a
step2 going to let me be involved with
whoever it is that to move and sell any
kind of super illegal product and that
sorta Tiger would be I make up as their
a black market is there a birthmark it's
not America there's a black market in
Laos or Cambodia or you know places in
Southeast Asia where people still
readily consume Tigers the greatest
threat the tiger has is being consumed
by people who think that the incredible
power and grace of the tiger will be
given to them somehow by eating its
parts and pieces all the way from its
testicles to its whiskers a different
part yeah different vibe
and fix you up but in America a tiger
cub is precious and amazingly rare there
is no surplus of tiger cubs in North
America there's virtually no one doing
anything with comes except the
characters on the film of which most of
those people are out or on their way out
they no longer have a license you know
there's there is no more Tim Stark
there is no more of a number of those
characters and if they're not they're
right on the precipice of falling off
we've never had a single violation of
any kind and at the end they also said
we were raided
we're not yeah yeah you guys had that
raid we're December they said you guys
had a raid that came through their dock
for the past we had an inquiry from
Virginia magistrate there who wanted to
get some DNA from some lion cubs that we
had and so what are they doing with the
DNA do you think somebody in Virginia is
having a meltdown case with them about
animal rights thing you know in a small
hometown zoo that they don't like and
they want to close it down they have
closed it down he didn't explain to them
in some capacity what they what they
wanted to hear about some baby lions
that were born there Lions were born
there he called me and said I have lions
I can't take care of would you take them
I would be happy to give them to you he
said yes my daughter got in car picked
him up and brought him back completely
legal transaction
everything's michi I didn't tell anybody
what he did he didn't explain it right
he gotten some beef with them and they
came down here to say do you have those
lines and I said yes they said we
believe you but we have to have in
equivocal proof we've got to know that
that's the lines let's take DNA from
those lines and we'll be on our way
I was never found or even questioned of
doing anything wrong having skin or any
line of any weirdness here with a wild
life having this amazing set up go on
and just trying to make things smooth
for the guest could see us and everybody
have the greatest experience before it
seems one evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one